The plants themselves. Yeah, it's
all, it's all very strange, man.
There's no way out man.
There's no way out of this.
But in their eyes even there
was no way out. It's the out.
It's the path of least pain and suffering.
And I would tell those folks,
I respect the shit out of
that and I'm trying to do,
I'm trying to take my own this into my
own hands and actively in a more tangible
way.
Your hands off I'm hands on is the way
that I would say that and I respect the
hands off.
I respect like that.
I'm cognizant of what's happening
here and I'm trying to make it better.
I respect that. I, I feel what you saying
and I see what you're trying to do.
But if I'm thinking through the eyes
of a Vegan, you can go fuck yourself.
I'm being the nice guy and you're in a
dick like vegans. A lot of them are dicks
cause wiling and eating animals. You're
killing animals. He fucking asshole.
You think you got a free pass?
Just kill animals and time you bond.
You don't, some of them. So I liked
this devil's advocate side of new Joe.
Thank you. Did you see Moby ever?
Look at Moby's page. Never helped.
It's a wonderful Instagram page and
everything be something that was so
preposterous the other day. And uh, I
read the comments under it. I was like,
this is so hilarious about eggs
and uh, this is what it's, I mean,
first of all folks, you kind of
talking to a person who has chickens,
eggs are like the most Karma free thing
says eggs cannot legally be labeled as
healthy, nutritious, or
safe to eat. First of all,
this is true because the eggs are
full of cholesterol and saturated fat.
And because every year over a hundred
thousand people in the u s contract,
Salmonella from eggs, they cannot legally
be advertised as healthier, safer,
nutritious. Okay? First of
all, this central, okay, I
dunno why you posted that Moby.
You didn't look into it. Is
there something called add
vault at animal equality?
How many people get Salmonella
from eggs every year?
Because if it was 100,000,
the fuck that shouldn't be in the news,
Bro would collapse. So God
damn fast, so let's dismantle.
Please go ahead and do that.
Does dismantle this preposterous idea
that 100,000 people get Salmonella.
Okay, here we go. Even
with safety steps in place,
it is estimated that about one in 20,000
or one in 10,000 eggs are contaminated
with Salmonella. Wow, that's
a lot is movie, right?
What does he, what did he say?
100,000 people get it right,
but we see if you could find how many
people in the u s contract Salmonella,
because if they find out
that this salmonella in eggs,
are they finding out that's
from uncooked eggs every year,
about a million people get Salmonella
infected from foods that had been
contaminated by one of the many
kinds of Salmonella. Is he right?
Okay. Let's, let's see if
it's 100,000 people from egs,
how many people per year
get salmonella from eggs?
Where does it say Salmonella
in the United States?
142,000 people in the United States
are infected each year with Salmonella.
Whoa. Hold on. That says from
chicken eggs. Wait a minute.
142,000 people in the United States are
infected each year with salmonella from
chicken, eggs, and about 30 die
dude. Not only is Mobi Mobi, right,
but he's off by 42,000 now you're going
to be way more of a devil's advocate.
I'm going gonna hit you hard with this
stills out. Let's go on. What'd you do?
Have any egg, egg related kind of
salmonellosis. That's what gives
what it is when you get it.
So we found that this is true
thousand. Yup. Not only is it true,
it's from 2010 maybe it's different.
In 2018 142,000 people in United States
are infected each year with Salmonella
and
enter itis cinder.
I end or Itus and Titus and writers
from chicken eggs and about 30 die.
So he lost 30 pussies in 2010.
And analysis of death certificate,
joking, joking. It's just a
joke. How many podcasts we're in.
The comedy section of Itunes,
uh,
identified 1,316 salmonella
related deaths from 1990 to 2006.
Whoa. Whoa. Now, thanks for
[inaudible]. But this is a problem.
These fucking dummies are eating them raw.
This is what I want you to Google.
How nutritious our eggs.
How about Google this?
Because a lot of ways,
situational fucking life,
I've never gotten salmonella were pretty
good. You look great. You're doing fine.
By the way, if you eat chicken
raw, you get Salmonella to stupid.
You're not supposed to eat it
raw. I supposed to cook it. Okay.
One egg has only 75 calories,
but seven grams of high quality protein,
five grams of fat and 1.6 grams of
saturated fat along with iron, vitamins,
minerals,
and Kara carotinoids.
The AG is a powerhouse of disease fighting
nutrients like Lutein and Zeaxanthin.
Okay, movie, so shut the fuck up.
They're super, super nutritious for you.
Just occasional back off Moby.
Somebody gets Salmonella.
How about just cook your
fucking fucking eggs,
but here's where it gets really dark.
Why don't you Google this?
How many people die every year from
Ecolab? From vegetables. That's right,
cause a shitload anti corn is
actually from farmed animals.
That's actually from agricultural
runoff from the, let's Google,
how much methane comes from how
much methane comes from vegans,
Broccoli. It's dead. Like hell.
Yeah. Let's come back to this.
Like where do you play the Wii?
And it's fun. Just love him.
He's so right. He's not just
writing. He's, he's more than 40,000.
[inaudible] Moby please. Uh,
just six degrees of Mobi.
Edit your post with the correct number.
Write about like eggs or dangerous bro.
Don't eat them wrong, like
good diet. Don't eat them raw.
Stupid. Okay, here it goes.
CDC estimates 260 out.
Wow.
265,000 infections occur each year
in the United States of ECO lie.
Wow.
36% are caused by e Cola.
Zero one five or 7.87.
Dude,
it's almost all from animal agriculture
is almost all from uh, from Shit,
from Shit.
Water types of Ecolab can cross islands
can be transmitted through contaminated
water or food to contract with
the animals where people, yeah,
but when they say contaminated water,
what they really mean is that water's
contaminated with shit from animal
agriculture. I think almost
entirely. What is the timeline?
The source of Eco Lie?
The Google this most prominent
source of eco lie from in vegetables.
I would guarantee you it's um,
animal agriculture. I mean,
if you see those gigantic factory farms,
the runoff and most prominent
source of Nikolai and vegetables,
is that what you said?
Because you're better at this than maybe
you just need to figure it out. Get it,
Joe. You find it, you find the
evidence. I'm trying to be,
I'm trying to be a can mobi.
Yeah. I'm trying to be a Vegan.
I'm not arguing for the vegans.
Vegans, I like this. I like this.
It's not hard to do. It's hard to do
it. It's a respectable position, man.
It just is. It's all three
actually. Was this most prominent,
the thing that popped up as the most
common way to acquire you eye infections
can be pasteurized milk,
fresh produce.
And that fresh produce means not
cooked. So if you get Broccoli, spinach,
you're supposed to cook spinach,
celery,
and that's a problem with Romaine
lettuce, right? Because Romaine is,
nobody ever cooks that
stupid fucking shit.
I fuck the world had no Romaine lettuce.
Do you think you'd be okay?
I think it'd be fine. Dining calls
it the hard lettuce. He's like,
I don't want that hard. Let
us give me the soft. Oh,
I don't like giving the soft
lettuce iceberg is just a joke.
That's just room for meat.
I could be putting meat in my
stomach instead of that shitty ass.
It's just delicious. And the
lettuce. Yeah. Listen, I should say.